- Let's go back even further
though; tell us about this.
Yeah!
(laughter)
Get it, get it!
You don't care, I don't care, look at me.
Ayyy
- I'm energetic.
- Yes! Body roll.
Oh you went off stage!
(audience cheering)
You went off stage!
- You know...
- [Kelly] You exited!
- Yeah.
- You danced and you exited.
- Back then, you know, like
MC Hammer was like the thing.
- [Kelly] The typewriter!
- You're doing like the snake.
- I know the typewriter!
- You know what I'm saying?
- Yes, yes!
- And like the running man,
was the real running man.
- Yes!
- And it wasn't like this
little running man are doing now.
And yeah, I mean I was
energetic, I was passionate.
- [Kelly] What was that school?
Is that like a school talent show?
- Yeah it was a school
talent show in Italy,
and my sister was a part of
it, and an act dropped out
and so she asked me if I would do it,
and big sister kinda was like,
hey listen, you're doing it.
And so I did it.
- Oh, so y'all are like close.
- [Kobe] Yeah, yeah.
- That's cool.
- So I did that show.
- When do you think my
children will be close?
When do you think that's gonna happen?
All my children, we got four,
and they're all like
(makes explosion noise)
- Yeah, well you know how it is.
It just happens, and
then as they get older
I think they get a little closer,
it hasn't quite happened for us yet.
- [Kelly] Me neither!
- But like, they're
close, but they're not.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- They love each other,
- They battle
- but don't necessarily
want to tell each other.
- It's like Game of Thrones.
Which one is gonna be the ultimate?
- Who's gonna sit on the iron throne.
- Yes! It's crazy!
- And ours is 16; we got 16,
13, two soon to be three,
and one that just turned four months.
- Whoa! You tired.
Four months!
- Listen...
- Or she's tired!
- I'm okay, yeah she's
like, finally you're home,
you get the chance to
do something, versus...
- We have four too, and it...
But yours are all girls.
- All girls.
- [Kelly] That's a lot of estrogen.
- Yeah...
(audience laughter)
- Like you went from
hanging out with all dudes
to like just rocking with women.
- Pretty much.
- Yeah that's a lot.
- It's a'ight. I just leave
the remote where it is...
(laughter)
I'm not fighting that battle!
I'm not.
- You just know.
- No, no.
- [Kelly] You're never gonna win.
- I just come downstairs,
change the channel
- I'm just like.
(laughter)
- All we watch is animated stuff, so yeah.
- So you probably watch
a lot of like Moana?
- Dude I saw you singing
Moana on carpool karaoke,
I was singing along with you.
- Well, how did I do?
- [Kelly] You did great!
- Yeah?
- I thought it was so sweet
to see a grown man like...
My husband sings to my children, I mean.
- You kinda have to though.
- Yeah!
- If you're changing them
on the changing table,
and you see them start kinda go...
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Real quick.
- [Kelly] Gotta make it happen.
- ♪ I been staring at the edge of the... ♪
(laughter and clapping)
And they're like.
They start smiling.
- [Kelly] And light up!
- Yeah, and all of a sudden I turn it,
I go from, I turn from black
mamba to the white mamba.
- The white mamba!
(laughter)
- I can sing now!
- That's your other alter ego,
- Yeah!
that's what we've found, okay.